Speaker 1: Well, Donald Trump actually held
a rally in Georgia on Saturday.
We did a live stream on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook, and he actually sort of had some
new material for once.
You know, these these Trump rallies have been
the exact same material for a very long time.
Communists and Marxists are taking over.
The country is ruined.
Unless you elect me, unless you reelect me,
unless you put me back in office.
As the sort of shifting narrative has been,
no one's making money any more.
You know, under Biden, you'll have to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times.
Hillary did bad stuff.
The crowd chanting Lock her up like a time
machine back to the year 2050.
And so it was a lot of repetition, but he
decidedly and notably added that we need to
take our country back by winning in twenty
twenty two.
We predicted this.
You predicted this.
We all predicted this when we wondered how
long is this going to go on?
Right.
In December, the Supreme Court will say it
was actually Trump who won.
It'll be overturned in January and then January
became March, which became April or August
or, you know, whatever.
We knew that eventually it would be.
Well, the midterms are coming up and the way
to take it back is just to win in twenty,
twenty two.
That shift seems to have started.
And we saw Donald Trump on Saturday start
to focus on the midterms in addition to calling
Joe Biden a son of a bitch.
OK, we're going to get to that.
That that.
Yes.
A former president calling the current president
a son of a bitch.
It was deranged.
It was loony.
It was humiliating.
It was pathetic.
But this is a political movement with power,
at least for right now.
And they are shifting to twenty, twenty two
and they could win in twenty twenty two.
Trump praised the Border Patrol agents seen
whipping Haitian migrants with horse rains.
Remember, they said they weren't whips, so
they weren't being whipped.
Well, you could whip someone with a horse
race and that's what they did.
This is the exact type of rhetoric that fueled
the El Paso shooter during Trump's presidency.
Take a look
Speaker 2: at tens of thousands of illegal
immigrants have overrun our borders in recent
days while laughing in the faces of our Border
Patrol agents.
And they're going after the riders of the
horses, not the people that came in illegally.
Isn't that incredible?
And they've just put them under watch.
They're in big trouble.
The riders of those horses, most people would
say they were doing one hell of a job, don't
you?
They're in trouble, can you believe
Speaker 1: so, ramping up the red meat, the
crowd tuning in and out, as they often do
during these rallies, but really loving that
type of stuff, and then Trump going very quickly
into 20, 22.
This is the new thing starting to talk about
2022 and Pelosi and more.
This is the shift we predicted.
This is the shift we've been waiting for.
It's happening now.
Speaker 2: George is going to be a central
battleground in our fight to rescue our beloved
nation.
We have great, great people running.
Many of them are right here.
I love Marjorie.
With your help, we're going to take back the
House and Senate, Nancy Pelosi back to San
Francisco.
Where she can work very hard to bring back
a city which he has helped to very much destroy,
just like they're destroying our nation, they're
destroying our nation.
We're going to fire your ultra left wing senator,
Ralph Warnock, and elect the great Herschel
Walker to the United States Senate.
And we're going to take back our country
Unidentified: from these lunatic.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, the question really
should be what happened to getting back in
right, the lawsuits, the fundraising, it was
going to be December, January, March, April.
That's just gone.
I guess it is predictably so, but no questions
being asked about what happened to all of
that, taking it back now stuff.
Now, you might have thought now that the Arizona
audit showed that Joe Biden actually won Arizona
by even more than originally reported, that
Donald Trump would ease up on the voter fraud
stuff.
But no, Trump never does that.
Trump never said.
I joked with the live audience.
Guys, do you think Trump is going to say,
hey, we got the real Arizona audit results?
And it turns out Biden did win.
I was wrong.
Sorry about that.
Biden did.
Of course not.
And Trump doubled down and he actually floated
the idea without any evidence whatsoever that
maybe Barack Obama didn't really win in 2012.
Speaker 2: And most presidents go down in
the second term.
Even if they win, they go down.
Obama went down, way down.
But he won or I don't know, maybe he won.
Who the hell knows?
Everyone nowadays with these elections, who
knows if he won?
But he went down a lot and he won.
Speaker 1: So, of course, there is no evidence
of that.
But this is the game.
If you're not sure who won 2012 as a Republican,
then maybe Donald Trump really did win in
2020.
That's kind of like the base level game that's
being played here.
And sadly, it has work to capture the minds
of tens of millions of these Trump.
And unfortunately, you know, Sam Harris actually
had a very good piece.
He got a question from a viewer about, hey,
why don't you have on like Brett Weinstein
and some of these people talking about ivermectin
and all this stuff and debate them.
And Sam made a really interesting point.
Whatever you think about Sam Harris's politics,
he said the problem with these debates where
you have like a contrarian, is that at any
time they can say, but what about X?
X could be anything.
And if you don't know about X to a lot of
these folks that have fallen for the big lie,
it comes off as low.
You're not ready to rebut X, then the conspiracy
theorists must be right.
And this is why as Trump went further and
further into stuff and said, hey, you know,
there were 5000 people.
About whom there was no record, for example,
which is like really vague language, if you're
not immediately ready with an answer, the
types of folks that go to these rallies go,
wow, 5000 people with no record that they
were supposed to be voting in that county.
I don't even know what that means, but nobody
is rebutting it.
So it furthers these conspiratorial beliefs.
So it's very hard to kind of like put them
back in it, put put them back in the bottle
for lack of a better term.
Trump even then mentioned and this is just
red meat, right, that he's never actually
conceded 2020.
Now, remember, concession is a mere formality,
but it's another reminder to fire up the big
lie people and the people who think maybe
Trump will come back, take a look to
Speaker 2: a great pollster.
So we got 63 million.
He said, sure, if you go up one million votes,
you can't lose what we went up 12 million
votes and they say we lost, but there never
has been.
You know, there never has been a concession.
You do know that, right?
Speaker 1: The crowd, including the strategically
placed blacks for Trump who were on stage
right behind Trump, really reacting to that
one, as you could tell, the crowd tuning out
for large portions of this, but getting pulled
back in by xenophobia, getting pulled back
in by the stuff about voter fraud, as Trump
calls it.
Now, in this next clip, Donald Trump actually
admits that he called Brian Camp in Georgia
after the election and asked him to do a new
election, a so-called special election just
because.
Why not?
Right.
Maybe Trump would have won that one instead
of Joe Biden news.
Speaker 2: But I said to these young people,
let me handle that.
I was going to show them how good I am.
Let me handle it.
I come up, I said, Brian, listen, you know,
you have a big election integrity problem
in Georgia.
I hope you can help us out and call a special
election.
And let's get to the bottom of it for the
good of the country.
Let's get to the bottom of it for the good
of your state.
Let's go.
Election integrity.
What could be better than that, sir?
I'm sorry.
I cannot do that.
Speaker 1: Well, now, Kemp was right.
You can't just say, I don't know, let's do
another election because you don't like the
results.
Sir, you can't do that.
Kemp was right.
Trump mentions Mark Zuckerberg from Facebook.
The crowd starts chanting, lock them up.
And Trump says, yeah, we we should look at
that.
Speaker 2: Shows also took forty million dollars
from Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg to fund election
related activities.
Well, they should be looking at that.
What is that all about,
Speaker 1: so completely dystopian, completely
authoritarian?
I am increasingly convinced that Facebook
is a net negative for society, but lock up
Mark Zuckerberg.
It's the same type of authoritarian stuff
that they claim to be for law and order and
due process, except when it's the Trump rioters
subjected to that process, they say, oh, no,
no, just let them out and let you know whatever.
And then when it's someone they don't like,
like Mark Zuckerberg, just lock them up, lock
them up.
What crime is even suspected of guys? Trump
also tried claiming that the Arizona so-called
audit, which remember it, confirmed that Joe
Biden one actually says Trump one.
It's all lies.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Yesterday, we also got the results
of the Arizona audit, which.
Which were so disgracefully reported by those
people right back there in the headlines claiming
that Biden won.
That Biden won our fake news at a very big
lie, you know, they like to you ever notice
when they write about that, they would say
while the election results are a big lie,
Speaker 1: even the biased audit.
Confirmed that Joe Biden won and we're going
to we're going to talk about that, Trump then
called for Arizona's 2020 results to be, quote,
decertified.
Sir, they just confirmed you lost.
What are you talking about?
Speaker 2: Decertification, the total decertification.
It is clear in Arizona that they must decertify
the election.
You heard the numbers and those responsible
for wrongdoing must be held accountable.
It was a corrupt election.
Speaker 1: Trump is the one responsible for
the wrongdoing and he should be held accountable.
Without a doubt.
No Trump rally is really complete without
some glitches and short circuiting.
Trump, short circuited on the word obliterating,
came up with a militarizing just a little
bit of the flavor and color.
Speaker 2: But Joe Biden is obliterated.
It's just obliterating.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And then he also had a doozy of a time with
military installations, which I guess instantly
is the way he sees them,
Speaker 2: military institutions and their
installations.
And they have a lot of things surrounding.
Speaker 1: Maybe he meant instantiation somehow.
I don't I don't really think so.
And then the former president also claiming
that people are finally starting to say Merry
Christmas.
But the truth is, no one really stopped.
This is just that culture war stuff.
But he did pull that out as well,
Speaker 2: that too much.
And, you know, they are starting to say very
strongly, Merry Christmas.
Remember when I first ran, I said, you're
going to say Merry Christmas.
They're all saying Merry Christmas again.
We better move fast because that'll end also
like everything else.
Speaker 1: So, again, the the very interesting
trend, as we've talked about how the Republican
Party has been totally devoid of policy for
at least as long as Donald Trump has been
at the forefront, you can tell in the reactions
of the crowd they get bored when Trump reads
numbers or when he goes into anything that
could be considered remotely policy oriented,
of which there's very little didn't even really
policy.
It's just like lies about the policies you're
ascribing to others.
The crowd turns out they're interested in
xenophobic stuff about it was great that the
migrants were being whipped.
They tune into voter fraud stuff and they
tune into the culture war stuff.
We will say Merry Christmas or we've been
saying it thanks to me or whatever.
And then, like I said at the top, yeah, Donald
Trump referred to Joe Biden as a stupid son
of a bitch.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: And they understood that.
That's why I told you before eighteen months
we didn't have one soldier killed.
And even Biden said that it was a mistake.
They said he said, while I will say that no
soldiers have been killed in 18 months and
it's people screaming at them, don't say that,
you stupid son of a bitch.
Speaker 1: So, again, the crowd really loving
it, just absolutely loving that.
So a wild rally and listen, for now it's clear
Trump's going to be involved in 2022 depending
on who wins and loses, depending on whether
Republicans are seen as being strengthened
by the midterms or further weakened, he will
stay involved before that.
We don't know yet.
It remains to be seen, but there's lots and
lots of work to do.
And I do to some degree coincide with the
Brian Stelter article we looked at earlier.
I think all of this together, the resurgence
of the rally, the Trump interviews, the escalated
conspiracy theories being spread related to
the election now that we're close.
I mean, listen, we're almost a year out, guys.
I do think there's something brewing here.
It may just be some really low information
way to try to win the midterms.
I don't know yet, but we're going to keep
following it and we'll have more on this on
our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.